the discomfort around the idea of doing
nothing I think is worthy of
Investigation 100 why wouldn't I go in
and hang out in beautiful places around
the world and beaches and just relax and
just do something else and not be
obsessed and it is it's an obsession my
team know it's a seven day a week
everywhere I go Obsession why
I
[Music]
Stephen
how are you I'm good I'm good I'm
feeling really really good I ask you
that because that's how you typically
begin all of your interviews and I'm
curious why you asked that question at
the beginning of your interviews
particularly in light of this idea that
you talk about in the new book around
grabbing people's attention in the first
five seconds because that question
doesn't feel like an attention grabbing
type of
situation so I asked that question when
I feel like the person sat in front of
me might have a honest important answer
to that question that that Buck's the
trend of just giving a flippant yeah I'm
good thank you and I also ask it because
there's no amount of research that I
could have done beforehand to understand
how someone's truly feeling in that
moment how they're feeling in that
moment then drives the rest of the
conversation profoundly and I've had
instances where I've done days of
research and I've walked in and sat with
Simon sinek and said how are you feeling
and he's responded I'm feeling really
really lonely right now
in that moment all of the research goes
out the window and the next two and a
half hours are about loneliness
and so that's where I was the question
yeah I uh watched your latest Vlog last
night and a couple things uh stuck out
from that viewing experience the first
of which is
the incredible amount of of endurance
that you bring to what you do because in
one day you did a public appearance in
the morning you then did three
back-to-back interviews for Diary of a
CEO I think I've only done three in a
day once I don't know how you have the
energy to maintain Focus for that
extended period of time and then you did
a live event with Simon that night in
front of 3000 people in which what you
just uh what what you just referenced
came up this idea of him
making the choice to be open and
vulnerable in that moment and how that
created a really unique and meaningful
conversation for that episode
so once your question then In This
Moment how I'm feeling is I feel like
I've overextended myself in my life
I feel like 12 months ago or six months
ago I must have said yes to too many
things and not have been cognizant of
the nature of my the fact that my time
is finite and this is a constant battle
I have in my life which is my ambition
is maybe exceeding my capacity
um which I need to put into check
because I pay the price for that I end
up having letting someone down somewhere
and also therefore myself in the process
and right now where I'm at I've
definitely taken on too much stuff so
endurance is great what we need is
consistency and sustainability we don't
need intensity intensities may be useful
in in spurts but you can't maintain
intensity for a consistent enduring
period of time nobody can without
something Falling by the wayside that
matters yeah I think uh if something
is on the calendar long enough into the
distance almost always invariably say
yes to it only to Woe the day when when
it arrives and I'm constantly in that
battle of trying to protect my time
versus uh you know how that meets up
with the goals that I'm setting for
myself and the people-pleasing
tendencies that that tend to creep up
where I want to be able to do right by
my friends or you know kind of fulfill
uh you know a certain role that I'm
privileged to hold right now and I would
imagine that you're
uh in a similar situation in it just at
a 10x kind of volume
yeah unfortunately so fortunately and
unfortunately so and I the the frame I
try and apply to the decisions when I
see something on my list a request that
comes in is how would I feel if I had to
do that tomorrow and that's the frame I
should be applying which is how would I
feel if I had to do that later on today
or tomorrow because I fall under the
same bias which is I defer it to a
future Steve who I can't yet understand
the circumstances of the day that he's
currently in and by bringing it to
today's Steve it kind of helps me filter
out things against my values and
intentions
um and that whole frame generally I was
talking about this last night one of my
friends of really being cognizant that
when you wake up every day after
spending eight of your as I talk about
my first book proverbial chips on sleep
you have these 16 chips left and how you
place those 16 chips on the roulette
table of life is the center point of
your influence on your own life the
allocation of those 16 chips on this
proverbial roulette table of life and
when the wheel spins every day you find
out the returns you've got so these 16
chips how do I place them and what are
my values and you're trying to place
them where your values are and if you if
you land on your values you get great
returns so placing two against spending
time with my girlfriend in the evening
placing four against my podcast four
against my businesses two against DJing
one against Jim that's a that's time
I'll spend and I might also it's
important to say this I might Place one
against binging Netflix if it was
intentional it's not wasted time it's
only wasted time in my regard when you
you didn't do it consciously and
intentionally
um and that framework is so important
because if you look at anyone's how we
allocate our time it's so clear we think
we're going to live forever it's why on
all of my desks on my bookshelf behind
me on the Diary of a CEO I have this
sand timer because I don't believe
humans can imagine in in infinity or
finality I don't think we're capable of
such a thing so we we allocate our time
in um trivial regrettable ways but our
time is literally the currency we have
the allocation of my time up until this
moment where I'm sat with you today is
the thing that has put me in this chair
today it's like well allocated time in
my regard because I managed to get you
know to have a conversation with you so
thinking through that that framework and
reminding myself that you know time is
so so precious and so finite
um allows you to hopefully make
decisions about
you what you're doing with your day that
are unregrettable which is my goal at
the moment yeah I think it it requires
very it Demands a certain
um type of discipline that might not be
immediately obvious because when we
think about discipline we think about
you know how hard can we work or how can
we make that hard choice to delay
gratification but discipline comes in
many forms I think the chapter in the
new book about discipline you come up
with this equation right about that
which kind of speaks to uh you know what
you just mentioned yeah and um you're so
right because when I was starting in my
career when I'm 18 and dropped out of
University and I I want to be successful
in my brain I want to be rich I'm going
to be honest I want to be rich and
successful in the first page of my diary
when I'm 18 shoplifting pizza pizzas my
diary says and I've uploaded this to the
internet I want a Range Rover Sport as
my first car
um I'll have a million from 25 I'll have
a girlfriend and a six pack that was my
North Star in life
um at that point I say yes to everything
anyone wants to meet me for anything I'm
saying yes as you become more successful
you need to invert that framework and
start saying no to most things and even
where I am now there'll be things that
come across my desk which are
um tempting my insecurities you want to
go to a Vogue party do you want to go
walk the red carpet the Oppenheimer
Premiere these are all things in the
last um do you want to go meet the king
at the at the palace you'll be there for
six hours you'll Network drink champagne
and meet the king these are all things
that I've had to contend with and all
things I've had to say no to because if
they don't I know in no way do they
bring me closer to the life and the
person I want to become going back to
this discipline equation thing that I
was writing about in the book I actually
the title of that law in my book was
about time it was about time management
I started out to write about time
management because everyone wants time
management techniques and as I go down
there and as I start doing my research
on time management techniques I
discovered there are hundreds
right and I also if I'm honest with
myself there's none that I use so I
asked myself why and in the same way
that there's lots of fad diets
um out there the reason why there's so
many time management techniques is
because none of them fundamentally work
so people keep going in search of new
ones and creating new ones because they
lack the fundamental um skill of
discipline so I asked myself okay
um why does discipline matter well in a
world where time is finite as we've just
discussed you can only do so many things
and so I try and figure out why in some
areas of my life I've been disciplined
with the gym six seven days a week with
DJing with my businesses and why in
other areas of my life has my discipline
lapsed so I tried to write a simple
equation
which is and I would love to you to
interrogate this with me because I'm
still you know trying to refine the
equation but at the start of the
equation you have
in simple terms
um why does the goal matter to you
right plus the psychological enjoyment
you get in the pursuit of the goal minus
let's call it the psychological
um disengagement or the psychological
friction associated with the goal so
with going to the gym I started going in
the on March 2020 and I've been going
for over three years now March 2020 I
watched a pandemic sweep the world and I
watched through my TV screen people
dying because of Health
um uh Health their health circumstances
and the correlation between outcomes in
your health circumstance it was so
traumatic to me that it increased my why
to con to so much so that the Habit
stuck and I was so clear to me now that
the foundation of all my goals my
businesses my goal from my relationship
my dog my family was my health I saw the
tectonic plate Shake underneath
everything I care about
um The Pursuit itself of going to the
gym is psychologically enjoyable as long
as the gym is close and as long as
um it's private so I'm not spending a
lot of time just talking about the
podcast with people
um minus the friction Associated to it
so reducing the friction means me
finding a private gym I actually stopped
going to the gym when
my uh when people knew who I was because
I people came up to me a lot yeah
friction increased and Simon cynic
challenged this the other day with me
and he goes well you know like I get up
every morning and I go and empty the bin
outside my house because because I don't
enjoy that it's not meaningful to me I
go yeah but it is Simon because what
happens if you so if we examine that
through that framework what happens if
you don't empty the bin outside your
house Simon well you're gonna get fined
and it's going to overflow for the whole
week so your wire is actually pretty
high the psychological enjoyment is low
sorry the enjoyment is low and the
friction is high but the Y
is higher than the friction is getting
out of bed at 8 AM it matters more to
you the why the pursuit you know
achieving that goal then the um friction
is unmotivating for you if at some point
they reduced the why so you would no
longer get fines and you had a second
bin you wouldn't get out of bed the
friction would win out and so the reason
it's important to think through that
framework is you can influence it
if there's something in your life where
you're not disciplined you can focus on
those first that first half of the
equation remind yourself why this really
really matters to you and then do
everything you can to make the pursuit
of the goal as enjoyable and as engaging
as you can when I started learning to DJ
the game changer for me was moving the
DJ equipment down to my kitchen table
and saying to my girlfriend I'm so sorry
babe for the next 12 months please can I
have all of my DJ equipment always
plugged in with one button I flick
flicked to start it because when it
takes 20 minutes and it's in the spare
room it's too much faff and you know
confusion to get it set up yeah yeah I
mean it's basically about creating
systems that are conducive to the choice
you want to make being the convenient
and easy to access choice
um it reminds me of uh conversations
I've had with Dan buettner the the blue
zones guy he goes into cities and meets
with uh councilman and Mayors and
they're all about how do you create a
healthier popular relation and instead
of shaming people around their habits or
trying to influence them to eat better
or to ride their bikes to work you have
to create a a sort of city architecture
that drives people in the right
direction to make that choice so you
create bike paths and you create
Financial incentives to make those
choices and you remove the vending
machines out of the schools yeah city
offices so that that unhealthy Choice
becomes the friction to your point
becomes a little bit too much and the
healthier easier choice just creates uh
it it creates like an easy open kind of
revolving door towards that exactly and
it's the same in companies you know I
I've spent 10 years working with CEOs
and companies and they'll write on the
on the wall of the the office innovate
or they'll write these cliches and these
platitudes like fail faster I also went
undercover in a school four years ago no
about seven years ago on a TV show
um and I went in there as an expelled
student with a bias that teachers are
just not good at their jobs or maybe
they don't care because I was kicked out
of school and when I saw the incentive
structure and the Headmaster sat me down
and said by the way the reason why we
push kids to get grades and subjects
they don't like is because the amount of
kids that walk through the door every
year determines how much money the
government give us that decision is made
by the league table so the parents
looking at the league tables and
deciding if they should send their kids
here and the league table is determined
by the grades you get in these subjects
so the incentive structure in a school
isn't let's find out what ritual cares
about or why is Stephen spending all of
his time starting these businesses at 13
years old let's nurture that it's we
have to get him a grade in this subject
he hates or I watched Mrs Clowney have
to pay out of her own pocket to buy the
pencils and the footballs and the
Notepads for class because they they
were 50 under capacity and in
organizations CEOs go innovate but when
you look at job descriptions the job
description is do your job
do not take a risk right and so if you
want to cause innovation in an
organization focus on incentive
structures and that's what I do in my
own life I focus on my incentive
structures that point is made very
clearly in the book uh especially with
the team kind of section here how you
Empower people how you try to get the
extract the best most creative work by
fostering a culture of experimentation
risk taking failure all these sorts of
things but I want to get back to this
idea of discipline and tying your
discipline to a value structure removing
the friction I think these are all great
ideas but when I reflect on how you meet
out discipline in your own life I
suspect that you're somebody for whom uh
you know things like
hard work uh
uh taking risks
um
managing people like these are all
disciplines that you've mastered but
they're almost second nature in other
words I guess what I'm saying is I'm not
sure that they require a tremendous
amount of discipline or motivation on
your part so I'm curious around the
habits or the buckets in your life that
are demanding of your discipline but
which you still struggle yeah I would
say that working out is still one of
them going to the gym is still one of
them in the context of everything else
that you should look on my biceps you're
looking good Dad yeah but I know when
you were in L.A you were you were like
you know sharing stuff when you were at
the gym and yeah in L.A I had a strong
routine but it's still a struggle
because in the context of that day you
saw that you've referenced in my Vlog
when I've gone to the gym yeah I don't I
don't know that it happened that day it
did 30 at night but it was it was a 10
minute workout
so Simon invited me to the after party I
showed face at the after party for 10
minutes maybe less and then I slipped
out the back door and when my driver
dropped me at the gym and I did a 10
minute workout what's important for me
there is that I although it wasn't a
good workout I kept my obligation with
myself my own self story that's
something I continue to struggle with
and again it comes back to
um
overextending myself in terms of my
calendar and I have conversations with
myself all the time it's literally a
mental dialogue which is
a conversation about who I who I am and
who I want to be and how the person that
I want to be would be behaving at 11 30
at night on this particular night what
would he do and it's so interesting
that's why I talk about the self story a
lot because No One's Gonna Know
No One's Gonna know if I went to the gym
there's going to be no evidence or
results based on that 10 minute workout
but it's purely a story and a
conversation that I have with myself and
we all have a story about ourselves that
we don't know is governing governing our
lives and if I didn't go then it writes
a new little line into myself story
about the person I am
and it's a line in my story that I don't
want
and um having spoken to a lot of
professional athletes and such I I was
able to identify that this those stories
govern their lives when things are
hardest the most hardened might the gym
thing is a difficult thing for me at the
moment because I'm going I went
yesterday I had to go at 2PM just after
I met bunt into you in the street
actually just before
um but I struggle with that
but I fight to get back on the horse
every week yeah yeah but I think there's
something deeper around that which is
the self-esteem that you cultivate when
you are living your life in Integrity
with your values and if you establish
that as a key value uh this is who I am
I'm somebody who works out and you show
up for that in yourself when your head
hits the pillow that night you feel good
about yourself even if it was a 10
minute workout because you are true to
your own word exactly and I allocated
the time against my values you mentioned
story story is a whole section in your
new book as well the importance of
understanding Story how to tell a story
and uh and being connected to the story
that you tell yourself about who you are
and the story that you're sharing with
the world so if I was to ask you you're
an individual but you're also a public
person and on that level it you know as
as cringy as it sounds you are kind of a
brand right like what is the story
of you like how do you articulate what
that story is I have never really tried
to articulate what that story is I think
that that's so interesting given how
much importance you place in this idea
it's really interesting because I know
that
um the story of me exists in everyone's
life who experiences me and it's a
completely different story for them what
I the thing that I the controllable to
influence that story is my actions so I
was funny I just had my hand cut before
I came here my barber was cutting my
hair and he says oh man people walk into
the shop every day they're always
talking about you some people are saying
this about you some people are saying
this about you some people really like
you some people don't like you some
people don't understand you they're not
sure if you're black enough they're not
sure if you're this and I was just
thinking um to myself as he was saying
that there's this part of you that wants
to jump to control that maybe I'll stop
being more black maybe I'll start doing
this maybe I'll start you know and then
there's this other part that knows I'll
never be able to control that but the
controllable is I've got to keep doing
my self-justice and proud and then
um from that
everyone will write their own story some
people that'll be inspiration some it'll
be something else but I've never I've
never sat down and tried to like
articulate the story of me I'm an
entrepreneur I think I'm a creative more
than I probably let on
um because I'm because I think about the
work that I do and it's the creative
stuff
um and I'm someone that believes a lot
in themselves and really wants others to
believe in themselves more so they can
get close to their potential that's
maybe my story but I don't think about
it I want to uh double click on the
self-belief piece uh in a minute but but
before we get there
I was thinking
to myself in preparing for this like
what is it about this guy that's so
interesting and compelling and that that
that has him sort of standing out from
the crowd and in who he is and what he
does and I'm sure there's a number of of
reasons or things that I could identify
but the thing that really
I think my brain hones in on
is this notion
or this innate capacity maybe it's a
gift that you have or maybe it's a
discipline to come across wisdom
to learn things
which a lot of us can do but it's your
ability to then apply these things to
your life you're so young and so
accomplished at such a young age and I
see somebody who who who identifies a
good idea and then is able to
incorporate that into his life
and produce returns as a result of it
whereas most people I think really
struggle with this we can all read books
we listen to podcasts we're we're on the
receiving end of of good ideas quite
frequently but until we reach a certain
pain point or crisis point in our life
we're very resistant to Habit change and
to me from the outside looking in at you
you seem to have figured out a way to
remove that resistance and and kind of
lean into habit change with a little
more ease or or facility
it's interesting
such an interesting observation I one of
the things I've noticed about myself is
I'm not good at
overstaying my welcome in situations
where I don't feel good and I I'm also
someone that um doesn't
that often sees the thing you would
consider a risk I see that as the Easy
Choice and um I see the thing people
call the risk in my life as
um yeah the Easy Choice when I see the
risk so I'm really referring to key
moments in my life where I've quit stuff
I look at myself for
um 18 years old going to that lecture
and really hating it and deciding that
I'd never go back and I didn't write you
did one lecture business school yeah at
University and said that was it to me
the risk was staying but every interview
I do they say oh you've missed so much
courage I think the courage was staying
in a situation where I didn't feel good
and then my mum calling me and saying I
won't speak to you ever again if you
don't go back to University and me being
like that's okay she'll be fine
and that ease of moving away from
situations that don't serve me and
towards situations where I just feel
good inside which is this I can't
believe the world ignores it we all have
this like Compass this this thing built
inside us which is how do you feel and
it's so low on our on our order of
signals or voices that we tune into
which makes no sense to me everyone's
you know like above that people rank
their mother's opinion the girl on
Instagram that didn't like my nails and
for me the most important number one is
how do I feel and when you apply that at
a very young age where you can
gracefully move away from school at 14
years old and then get expelled they
actually unexpelled me because I was
making them so much money that's what my
Headmaster said on TV and it's true to
University don't like it there built a
startup for two years investors all of
that quit out of the blue my second my
third company quit out of the blue again
if you can gracefully use that signal
inside you which is how do you feel in
the situation and prioritize that I
think you get closer and faster it takes
less time for you to get to the life you
want and I'm so good at quitting like my
last company we were about to uplift
onto the the second a very large Stock
Exchange
and I quit because I just didn't feel
good anymore and it wasn't a difficult
decision for me and if you think about
what I left on the table in terms of
monetary value huge it makes no sense as
to why I quit there was no Branch I was
swinging to just don't want to be here
anymore
and that framework for Life creates the
impression that you're very good at I
don't know discipline or making
decisions whatever it might be but for
me it's I don't know why people hang
around in situations
um so long but you do you do know why I
think that that authentic Voice Within
all of us you can call it your gut
instinct or your intuition is certainly
uh you know a capacity that we all hold
but it gets worn down through social
expectations through societal
expectations through familial obligation
um and and just the confusing aspects of
of what it means to grow up and try to
figure out your place in the world and I
think uh you know with that we we tend
to repress that instinct if there's some
reason you were able to maintain it
perhaps it's uh in some people it's that
childlike nature and other in others
it's just a real strong sense of
identity or an antenna for what serves
you and what doesn't but I think it's
it's something that you've protected but
it's something that uh if left to our
own devices
um
and and without proper boundaries gets
eroded yeah and it's it's a signal like
hunger or thirst is a signal that it's
deep inside you and it's there for a
reason it's a signal a really important
signal that's hardwired into you from
from generation and generation and
generation like hunger and thirsties or
you touch something and it's hot so I
pay attention to that signal last night
but why how are you able to do that like
I just know never let me I only have my
own experience yeah and and I didn't
really begin to connect with that until
I was in my late 30s and early 40s no
one ever said to me like
what is it that you want to do what's
important to you what makes you feel
alive is there a way for you to feed
that or fuel that or honor that at least
that's not part of our education system
it wasn't really the way that I was
raised to no fault of anybody
perhaps mostly to my own fault for not
respecting it but that facility to
appreciate and respect that signal
within yourself I think is is almost an
act of of rebellion or you know what I
mean yeah I completely know what you
mean and I think this comes back to the
one skill that I think I have and when I
do an audit of how I came here versus my
brothers who are just these two super
Geniuses both older than me super
Geniuses one's a mathlete lse Cambridge
whatever geniuses then there's me the
thing that I have which is clearly
different from them I'm not smart that
them they're smart right they you are
smart I'm smart in a different way if
you if you gave me a GCSE which is the
the grading system we have in the UK I'm
so low on on those scores at 16 years
old is self-belief
and I know this is it sounds kind of
cliche to say self-belief but at 10
years old my parents stopped being
parents basically so I'm the youngest of
four they raised the other three and
when you get to the fourth one you think
oh kind of we've done it yeah and he's
kind I mean she's 23 21 18. he's 10 but
he's kind of you know
and they stopped coming home so my mum
would sleep in the back room of her shop
on a bag of rice and I remember going to
the shop and seeing that it had loads of
bite marks in it and going why is she
goes all these rats here I sleep here
because I'm being racially abused and
people break in at night so if I sleep
in the shop they're less likely to break
in my dad would then leave his job go to
her color shop and then in the evening
she would go to her restaurant right
none of these businesses ever didn't eat
well they were yeah your mom your mom
was a Serial entrepreneur of sorts she
still is
suffered from lack of focus yes perhaps
yeah and she didn't get an education in
Africa she left a school at seven years
old or something five or seven years old
didn't know how to read didn't know how
to write moved to the UK
I don't think she still knows how to
read and write
um so she was starting these businesses
they weren't going well my dad was
leaving his full-time job and going
straight to her
um and I was 10 and they forgot I was
10. so at that age I could leave the
house for two days and I could do what I
want and they genuinely there was no
repercussions and they wouldn't know I'd
left and what happens there when you've
got a kid who's the only black kid in an
all-white area and with a poor family
he's desperate to fit in and to have
stuff and you've given him this whole
void of Independence you've given him
all of this space to conduct experiments
about life those experiments lead to
failure and the failure leads to
feedback and the feedback is knowledge
and the knowledge is power so the thing
I look at with myself is I got to
conduct experiments at 10 years old
about the nature of what I'm capable of
whether it was selling the cigar cigars
my mum had bought from Nigeria all
around the city and raising loads of
money or at 12 years old going to my dad
I need 50 Quid because I've organized
this event 2000 um under 18s are coming
at this nightclub and they need me to
pay a deposit they think I'm 18. can I
borrow a 50 Quid I'll come back then
coming back the next day with a bag of
money and reaching into it giving my dad
his deposit back and going upstairs with
this huge bag of money I was conducting
these experiments at a young age they're
all reinforcing this thing we call
belief belief is evidence it is it is
subjective evidence you've chosen to
believe about yourself so that as a
macro Tailwind in my sales
from 10. to now
create somebody who will look at
obstacles and look at how they approach
things and have a huge optimism bias I
believe I can do it and that is
positively reinforcing upwards we're all
in a self-belief spiral upwards or
downwards some people are negatively
reinforcing and what I mean by that is
they're approaching the challenge at
work of speaking on stage with um
skepticism and fear therefore they show
up badly and even if they do a good job
because of that frame they interpret
they did a bad job which erodes their
self-esteem which means next time they
show up with even more pessimism if they
even raise their hand to show up and
it's this downward spiral since 10 I've
been on the opposite I've been on the
upward spiral tried something it could
be that the business I started at 10 or
12 years old it went well which which
meant that next time I showed up with
more optimism and belief which meant it
was more likely to go well and even if
it didn't I interpreted it well and
since 10 I've been like that and from
that has I've recruited a lot of
knowledge because I've been failing fast
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so I've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with that
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
but it's also a choice you could have
crafted an entirely different negative
spiral narrative about your upbringing
and your parents who are always arguing
and the grass that was never mowed in
your front lawn in the refrigerators
that were accumulating and being the
only black kid and I mean there's a
whole story there that you could have
nurtured around who you are and what
you're capable of so at some level you
make this choice to to invest in the
upward spiral narrative around your own
capacity so how do you is that is that
was that something that was conscious is
that its own discipline or is that a
preset default setting for you I would
love to say it was intentional and
conscious but I think we're all trying
to find ways to survive when we're young
and you have two ways you can survive
one of the routes to survive in that
context might be to fall back and fall
out of the situations I was in where I'm
I just remember this constant feeling of
like shame and insecurity and I need to
be enough and I was chemically relaxing
my hair to make it straight like my
white friends and I was like stealing
things so I could have the same shoes
that they had that was my way of
survival it was I will find a way I will
use that energy of Shame and that
motivator of Shame which Will Smith I've
heard him talk about before and I will
direct it towards fitting in at all
costs
and that was my my way and I'm probably
still doing that at some level yeah that
was my question is is is shame still a
fuel for you it's not it's not it's not
a great fuel source it's not a great
fuel source because you end up aiming at
the wrong things and when you get those
things they like they're like mirages
that just disappear in your hand as you
grab them and you realize that that was
not the thing there was nothing actually
there
um to avoid avoid you cannot fill so
shame is a hundred percent still a
motivator in my life I I always try and
be as aware of this as I can be so I
don't end up in the wrong place but I
know it is because
because sometimes I end up using the
wrong metrics to understand whether I'm
doing well
you know talk a little bit more about it
it's all like the comparative metrics
right like I've done a really good job
over the last two years to move away
from caring about these comparative
metrics but
um
why do I care about why do I care about
being successful
or being seen as successful why do I
care about that
it doesn't matter what matters is that
the impact our work is having and
outside of I've got Financial Freedom
now so why do I care about what people
um might think of me being successful
I'd say that's a that's there's a
percentage of that still there in me
um
that comes from the school situation
where I just wanted to fit in you know
had a lot well uh Impressions social
metrics have replaced the the luxury
Brands and the fancy car as a a marker
of status and it's a highly addictive
drug you're very good at it you're very
successful at it but even the best of us
are are are are hard-pressed to you know
resist the lure of what those numbers
mean and I know this has been a struggle
for you I am interested a little bit
more in the relationship between that
and shame because I think you are
somebody who learned early the false
promise of some of the material worlds
uh you know kind of
um uh lures so to speak uh and and did a
pretty good job of right-sizing yourself
around the true value of the Mansion or
the you know the Ferrari or whatever it
is but dangling right in front of your
eyes is subscriber counts yeah and how
many people you know rankings for your
podcast and the like which is something
that I struggle with as well
I sat down with a wonderful gentleman
who had written a book about status and
at this point in my life I don't have
um designer things per se you know don't
have the Rolexes don't have flashy stuff
really the most flashy thing in my life
is the I have a driver who drives me in
this Mercedes van and inside it it's
really nice
right yes you were very gracious uh take
me to a Premier League game yeah right
so so I got I had I had the privilege of
writing in that yeah so you've seen it
so that's that so I thought to myself
before I spoke to him that I'm not
playing status games anymore and what he
pointed out to me is
um when we don't have a lot of money the
logos are really big and then we have
when we're more sort of um successful in
our lives the logos shrink we start
playing different games so billionaires
it's all about the size of the boat but
they'll never wear like head to toe
Louis Vuitton no no if you go to
Nantucket everybody's driving kind of an
old car yeah or what you know what I
mean it's but that doesn't mean that the
status game has been erased yeah it's
just displaced with a different game
yeah yeah yeah and San Francisco they're
all driving test wrestlers but it's all
about either their fund size or the
startup that they're building so that
made me really aware that I'm I'm still
playing status games but it's a
different type of game and actually if I
was to walk in here head to toe and
Louis Vuitton it would actually be like
a counter signal to the status game I'm
playing because the people in my status
game now would think of me worse so it's
like and and he said to me you're still
in The Mousetrap though for the Maze and
he said to me we all are because status
really really mattered for survival
throughout human history so we're all
playing status games we it matters to
all of us that we fit in cancel culture
and rejection all of these things hurt
so badly because they are a prehistoric
signal that we've been kicked out of our
tribe and back in the day if we were
kicked out of our tribes we would die
our bodies change physiologically we
fall into this this Mode called
self-preservation when we feel it an
ounce of rejection we sleep worse we go
into higher um higher stress more
alertness because in a tribe the great
thing is there's so many people that you
can relax you all looking out for each
other you have different chronotypes
you're sleeping at slightly different
times more eyes and ears when you're on
your own you don't have that so the you
live it's almost a decade less long and
you're all your whole physiology changes
so when you get a metric changes it's
like the equivalent of the modern day
you see one of your metrics dipping down
it's in some ways a signal of rejection
that you're being kicked out of the
tribe at a deeper level and you get a
similar response oftentimes um or if
someone's commenting badly on one of
your photos even if you've got a
thousand positive comments that one or
two negative ones are they trigger that
sort of you know that any sense of
rejection
and all of the feelings that makes us
feel about ourselves so managing that
has for me been closing my context down
completely which is like if you tweet me
I won't see it if you know don't search
your name don't um look at your comments
as much as you can especially on like
you know like a cesspit cesspit apps we
know the ones yes and keep your contacts
super small that's really really helped
in my life but it's also putting the lie
to the whole notion that your status is
correlated with any of those things
truly right like can you transcend I
mean I'm sure some people can yeah yeah
yeah I don't believe I will in my life
as somebody who's so good at learning
something and applying it the friction
there with with uh you know still
struggling with that I just
I think speaks to just how powerful
these things are in controlling our
decisions our lives and our time
management I used to believe that my
body was against me in so many ways I
used to believe that it it was fighting
me trying to lose weight try not to eat
sugar
um trying to not to procrastinate
um trying not to care what people think
all of these things and if you change
the frame from why won't my body let me
do these things that I want to do in the
case of status why wouldn't it let me
stop playing status games or stop having
the cookie at 11 11 o'clock at night
when you look at the body and what it's
doing is it's trying to keep you alive
and if you look at it through that frame
your body is on your side and then if
you look at it through that frame status
games a survival thing
the sugar
I know 10 000 years ago would have kept
you alive if you came across it it
wasn't so abundant we didn't have
fridges in these things so your body
isn't against you it's doing everything
it can to keep you alive weight loss I
sat with weight loss experts and they
all said to me your body doesn't want
you to lose weight because your weight
actually correlated to how long you have
left to live
Once Upon a Time if you had more weight
you had longer to live and if you were
skinny when we didn't have an abundance
of food you had less time to live so it
tries to defend your weight at all costs
so your body's on your side
um status games are innately human
as is all these sort of diet and
discipline related habits that we can't
break that frame is helpful because yeah
I think it's also about agency right are
these things controlling you yeah or are
you driving them and I think to extend
your example you can also think of all
of your Character defects and defense
mechanisms all your your psychological
framework similarly I don't know if
you've had have you had Richard Schwartz
on no yeah so he has this he's a
psychologist
um with a modality called internal
family systems oh I've heard of it um
yeah ifs which is the idea that that all
of these we're all a multiplicity of
personalities and when we feel that
instinct to lash out or we're resentful
or fearful these are all just pieces of
ourselves that were designed to protect
us in the same way you know sort of uh
you know maintaining fat around the
belly serves Us in that regard and
understanding those impulses and and why
we created them for ourselves be becomes
very powerful in in learning how to act
in contrast to them and to have empathy
for yourself yeah I think yeah that's
the big piece too right to not think
you're useless right you've got no
discipline and you're lazy and why can't
I stop eating that thing or why can't I
stop playing this status status game in
terms of your own empathy for yourself
you mentioned shame but when you reflect
upon your childhood I also hear quite a
bit of gratitude like you are the way
you are despite some dysfunction and
whatever trauma you you you experienced
at that time clearly these things made
you who you are 100 didn't enjoy it at
the time but I wouldn't change any of it
now that might be some you know
survivorship bias whatever they call it
because I'm happy with where I am now
but I'm well aware that you change my
circumstances even slightly and I'm I
don't have a life that I'm happy with
today I reflect on my best friends from
that time none of them of my best
friends have left the city none of them
are in situations where they are happy
my mother did a fantastic brilliant job
of insulating us with very very harsh
discipline that I couldn't even tell you
about because you
you'd think it was inhumane or something
um but keeping us focused we couldn't
swear she couldn't read or write bear in
mind but she would get encyclopedias off
the shelf my dad was working
um for in London which is like what four
hour round trip away
for five days a week so this is this
Nigerian woman raising four children in
a house she would get that can't read or
write and she ended up raising a lawyer
uh and a like a super genius
mathematician I went to Cambridge and my
brother who's even smarter than all of
us and then me should get encyclopedias
and put them in front of us and say copy
from here to here to the end wow and I'd
copy them and then call my dad in London
and say Dad I just learned a new word
important
her discipline
um in those early years is profound and
watching her sleep on that bag of rice
taught me that hard work is not
something you complain about
like my mum never complained it's
something I always reflect on her life
was like no one's life I've ever seen
she worked from the minute she woke up
to the to the minute she fell asleep and
she didn't want say I'm tired she didn't
once complain it was and that maybe
speaks to where she's come from and what
she watched with her mother on those
stores in Africa that was so deeply
ingrained in me but I almost find it
hard to resonate with people who have a
pessimism bias because of that I never
saw it and what's your relationship like
with her now
um
it's
it's been on a journey it's been on a
really interesting Journey where when I
was 18 19 I was trying to intervene with
her businesses and give her advice and
she would never listen to me now she
listens a lot more because my life is um
has gone well in the business context
she never wanted me to be in business
as you can tell from that phone call
when she disowned me
um and I think she's still struggling
with being in this country far away from
home and being deeply misunderstood and
as I've grown up I've come to learn
about the racism she was telling me
about when I was younger that I could
never believe now I understand it I
understand what she was going through
being a Nigerian woman in the UK in 1992
in not just the UK but in the
countryside of the UK we're talking four
hours that way you know where everyone
is white
I can understand what she was going
through and I think she's still
suffering with the repercussions of that
racism she experienced
we we're not super close I'm close to
the rest of my family but um
we we talk
yeah
what would what would have to happen to
bridge that in a messy Gap with her what
is the barrier there you know what it is
I I thought I think I've this might be
because I'm mixed race or because she
came from Nigeria and I grew up in the
UK
it's how do we relate to each other
you know this is not she doesn't know
what the inter like understand the
internet and she doesn't understand what
I do
you know she seen me on the TV doing
Dragons Den but it's trying to find that
bridge that we can meet on and connect
on
uh which we I've always struggled with
and I've actually always struggled with
it with my dad as well
like I don't know what we talk about
um
and they don't they don't know me
they've that we've never I call them by
their first names I always have since I
was a kid never called the mum and dad
ever in my life not once ever what is
that about I don't know I don't know I
hear your siblings do the same yeah we
will do the same we call them by their
first names and we always have yeah
that's wild we my mum apparently said
when we were younger she wanted us to be
more like her friends than her children
so she and I think it maybe she didn't
want to feel old so we always cause
right right but do you feel like you
need your mom to understand what you do
no
so if you can liberate yourself if
you're liberated from that can't you
just meet her with compassion and a lack
of expectations
when we when we have our phone calls the
phone calls are my mom
talking about
her world for 30 minutes and what's been
going on in her day and then that's the
end of the call and it's not because I
don't have a desire to share yeah it's
there's no room in that conversation for
me to say anything I understand do you
see what I'm saying yeah yeah so yeah I
mean I'm not asked I mean she might ask
about my my girlfriend now but outside
of that there's no nothing about being
that cool it's about she wants to tell
me stuff yeah and then phone call ends
and that's our relationship yeah
sorry
I can relate
that's a different podcast but uh yeah
yeah I understand
um
one of the things I think is really
instructive and cool and interesting
about you is that you're you're very
consciously modeling a new uh a new idea
of what it means to be a leader and a
CEO throughout the 80s and the 90s me
being you know two decades older than
you
um
the people who are influencing what that
looked like were much more traditional
it was the Gordon geckos and greed is
good and when it all costs and never
show weakness never show vulnerability
and I think what you're showing up and
representing is something entirely
different and despite whatever you know
fuel sources you're relying upon
healthier otherwise like shame you're
sharing in real time that Journey for
the benefit of others and you're leading
with openness and optimism and and a
level of vulnerability that a couple
decades ago or not too long ago would
would have been frowned upon or looked
upon as a weakness in terms of how one
would lead teams and so I think there's
something really
interesting and instructive about those
choices and what it means in terms of
how other people show up to lead teams
to be leaders to be CEOs to be
Executives and just to be more fully
actualized human beings
you know vulnerability was a revelation
in my life and it was an experiment that
I ran
and I say this because as a man as a CEO
um sometimes it felt difficult to be
vulnerable right especially in my early
career because I still I'm in the wake
of theory that you've described and even
I growing up saw CEOs on TV as being
these like white men in suits that are
like yeah I never had them stop to talk
about what they were struggling with on
TVs in a movie and and about I'd say
five years ago I sat with my team
um and said I want to start podcast and
I wanna
be honest about what's going on in my
diary and in there it would include
everything from masturbation challenges
with my mother mental health anxiety
regretting decisions I made that day
and I want to just I want to put it out
there and see what happens and I say it
was an experiment because it's
terrifying to do that
that experiment putting that first
episode out there was the most
enlightening thing I've ever experienced
I thought vulnerability was a repellent
it turns out it's the world's greatest
magnet
it brings everybody to you if you think
about what's in greatest Supply in the
world it's the antithesis of
vulnerability it's filtering your life
and showing you know the best parts of
your life and that you're you're
successful and imperfect and all of
those things that's the thing that's in
greatest Supply the thing that's
fundamentally in the least is in highest
demand though is the thing that we can
relate to in the 99 of Our Lives which
is the struggle the insecurity the doubt
the eating the pot noodle on your bed on
your belly button at 1am in the morning
thinking about someone that's broken
your heart that's the thing in greatest
demand but in least Supply
and so it turns out
um also I came to learn a couple of
years later that we we when someone
shares their struggle it increases
oxytocin levels in us and we feel more
connected to them so I tried sharing
mine and it was the most profound
reaction I'd had from my best friends in
my life only my best friends listen to
it because it was episode number one but
what they said to me changed my life so
I wanted to continue that that
experiment of vulnerability in more
areas of my life including with my my
partner with my team members and with
the general public and it is win-win it
makes me feel amazing because I get
things that are trapped inside of me
running my unconscious mind like a
puppet master in the back room out in
the open and also other people can
almost relate to it and resonate with it
more than anything I could say if I sat
here now and said oh yeah I've got a
Range Rover Sport and a Ferrari and I
got a million pounds No One's Gonna Take
anything from that or feel connected to
that
but me talking about my mother and the
human sides of the 99 of my life
great for me yeah yeah great for them
it's interesting that that it began as
an experiment uh and and and you were
kind of calculating it in terms of
external response and my mind was going
to what was the internal barometer of
that because in doing that in in
summoning the courage to be vulnerable
especially in a public format
um is is a frightening Prospect yeah but
it's also incredibly
cathartic and empowering yeah and
liberating right because you're carrying
around that baggage and there is
generally a you know a piece of Shame
attached to these things because we feel
weak or insecure around those
vulnerabilities but in sharing them and
exposing them to the light we realize uh
one they didn't kill us two people
aren't rejecting us as a result of
sharing them and three uh by by putting
it out there it no longer holds power
over you in the way that it did when you
keep it in the shadows exactly that
Simon sinek's been on my podcast three
times and he said the third episode
where he opened up with I'm feeling
lonely he told me his entire social he
said all the other podcasts I've ever
done you know people might come up to me
and say that was a good episode that one
he said was it changed his life
his whole Friendship Circle is right
onto him messages phone calling him that
day people in the streets and cafes
coming up to him in his words crying
their eyes out why because Simon went
from being this great thinker and you
know great deliverer of ideas to being a
human being that we can relate to at a
deep level running the experiment of
vulnerability in more areas of your life
will be the greatest magnet towards
connection
um anyone could ever
could ever run sharing your struggle
honestly
um it almost bucks the trend because
we've been hardwired to believe that
people will be drawn to us if we are
perfect if we portray Perfection a great
lie it's the opposite completely
especially I actually think this has
been accelerated by the Advent of social
media the first chapter in social media
which I was a big part of I was running
a social media business at that time was
all about perfection then there was this
sort of counter movement
away from Perfection and towards
authenticity and that's where we live
now which is I think we're in the age of
authenticity where authenticity is an
unbelievable currency for you it's great
this is the important thing it's great
for you as well yeah but there's a
there's a caveat to that which is
what we now see quite a bit of is
performative yeah
uh which is which is you know sort of a
a false uh which is the council movement
right which which makes the whole word
uh you know authenticity devoid of
meaning it becomes a wallpaper word to
coin a phrase from from your book
um and then it becomes incumbent upon
the
um person on the other end of the phone
who's scrolling to discern the
difference between somebody who's truly
being honest and showing up and and
expressing from the heart versus the
person who's doing it for you know the
the likes and and the comments right and
I think we're good at telling the
difference I give people more credit for
that yeah and I think young people are
are extremely good at their the
detectors on young people are very
finely honed out of survival out of uh I
mean it's a it's a skill that's required
as somebody who grows up with technology
to understand the difference yeah and as
you say they've spent gen Z's have been
twin in many cases they've been in the
social media era for 20 years now so
every day for nine hours a day According
to some of the studies they are looking
at people's performances and almost as
if they're they're training the the
through machine learning in their brains
what authentic looks like and what it
doesn't look like and when someone's
lying to you when they're not when
they're being honest and when they're
being dishonest the world's greatest a B
test on a generation of humans and how
they behave and what they're what their
what their intentions are which maybe we
you know my dad didn't have growing up
maybe in a day he didn't encounter a
thousand people but the Gen Z's in my
office are scrolling through thousands
and thousands of performances a day so
their barometer has been finely tuned
and what is that doing to Jesus brains I
don't know
I don't know I don't want to think about
that
as somebody who's in that ecosystem in
in that business
um I don't think it's doing a good thing
I don't think it's doing good things for
sure um and I was actually as I was
getting my haircut the Barbara had
brought his two-year-old son and to keep
the two-year-old son occupied while I'm
getting my hair cut he obviously places
the phone there and the phone is
hypnotized this two-year-old the t-road
is literally and I said to him look he's
hypnotized and because he's just doing
the same motion back and forth looking
at the screen if you take that phone
away this kid starts running around and
grabbing stuff and playing the minute
you put that phone on Frozen I was
thinking there's something in that
two-year-old's brain that has is being
hijacked some kind of dopamine sure you
know it's the same with that and there's
a costume there's always a cost
so you conduct this experiment in
vulnerability in a public sphere by
launching the Diary of a CEO podcast I
went back and listened to a variety of
your very early episodes just super
interesting
um
actually the show has evolved quite a
bit uh since those early days but I
really like those monologue episodes I
find it very difficult myself to sit in
front of a microphone and just talk it's
much easier for me to you know kind of
do this sort of thing and it's easier
for me to hide a little bit right like I
try to inject just enough of myself but
it's not about me but when it's just you
talking into the microphone
sharing from the heart that that's a you
know that that requires something
altogether different
um I'm curious around the evolution of
the show obviously it's a you know
Global smash success and congratulations
I think you know it's it's well earned
and you know that I have huge respect
for
um what you do in the way that you do it
uh but I'm curious around why you don't
do more of those vulnerable check-ins of
all the requests we get the most
frequent one is people wanting me to do
that those first sort of 10 15 episodes
of all the requests I get I've put my
stories multiple times over the last
years I'm going to do it again I'm going
to do like my Steve's diary sharing
maybe seven points for my diary every
week where I'm just being completely
honest and open about what I'm thinking
what I've been struggling with
um
it was it actually the process of it
unlocked so many answers in my life more
than anything I've ever done it's why I
felt realized why I couldn't be in a
relationship why I was struggling to be
in a relationship from doing that
process of right in my diary reflect
upon it broadcast it teach it to the
world we broke up again
oh my gosh you've really listened yeah
yeah honestly it was it was um two
things the first is time takes much less
time for me to interview somebody else
um that's kind of a excuse
honestly like for me like to interview
someone else takes me
I'd say say three and two three hours
preparation time and then
the conversation will last three hours
it's about six hours in total for me to
sit down and and write through my notes
in my diary takes
I'd say nine hours solid
and I suppose I heard human talking
about his solo episodes and he says it
takes days and days yeah for sure that's
a very different thing yeah
that's why I think it is
and then interview and see I think
there's something
else I think there's a resistance
really because now the podcast is a
juggernaut and what you're doing is
working so well
so it's very easy
to not do the thing that you were doing
at the beginning
do you think I should yeah you think I
should yeah not every episode but once a
month maybe don't forget what inspired
you to do it to begin with
all right sup can I so just being
completely honest I just don't know
where I'd fit it my team always want me
to do it my team are like my team
actually put a solo episode in yesterday
and I deleted it from my calendar
because I was that day I was like I've
got too many meetings on and this is my
only day where I can sit down and work
so I delete it it's easy to remove those
ones apply your discipline equation I
don't know where I need to say anything
it fits squarely in the in the value in
in one of your value buckets yeah you're
right you are right I I
I honestly from the bottom of my heart
I can't add anything to my life right
now I can't add nine hours to my life
right now I I don't know where I'd add
it getting getting me to write the last
I told you yesterday I flew back to
London and wrote the last law in London
my manager who sat out there and he'll
know because he's lucky smoking and
putting his thumb my manager had to
chase me for three months to get me to
write that last law it's about four
pages
so to think I'd say I'd be able to sit
down maybe once a week and write what
solo episodes are about seven or eight
pages
I don't know how I would do that my Vlog
that I've started is my way of showing
you into my world a little bit sure but
that's a that's Day in the Life yeah so
I'm just challenging you please gently
here
the show is called diary yeah of a CEO
and it has become more and more
other people's diary yeah and not your
own yeah so just something to think
about I'm gonna do it
just put it on the calendar I mean a
month from now and I'm gonna do Audio
Only yeah so that it's easier for me to
right read from my notes and I don't
have to keep doing cuts and I'm gonna
run it as Steve's diary once a week or
once a fortnight on audio only there you
go I'm gonna hold you to that please
please the other thing that that uh I
noticed
yesterday when when I bumped into you on
the street
um that that that made me think that it
made you a little uncomfortable was when
we were taught you were sharing about
how you went away to finish the book
yeah and I was sharing that I do a month
sabbatical every year yeah and you
almost recoiled at the idea
um so when we talk about discipline and
hard work and Entrepreneurship and going
the extra mile and staying late with
your team and all the kind of
things that you think about when you're
trying to achieve a goal
the idea of stopping all together
to me feels like
a a healthy
um
uh pursuit of
that discipline
because I think it's easy for you to go
go go
but maybe it might require a little bit
of discipline to stop and understand
that that's part of the process also
that would be the hardest discipline for
me tomorrow right right right and it's
easy to be disciplined about things
other people think are hard but are
second nature to you
real discipline is applying it against
the things that you're most resistant to
so if we go back to the equation and
look at the the me stopping for a month
not doing any work for a month here's
all the excuses and all the reasons why
it's impossible why it's just not there
for me
so
you know you talk we often you probably
talk about in your show I talk about a
lot of mine that sometimes people need
to hit a rock bottom moment or a certain
level of pain before the why increases
right before they break the the cycle
that they're in for me the why is not
strong So when you say that my brain
goes yeah but why I don't need to stop
if at some point in my life whether it's
through having kids or whether there's
some kind of personal crisis in my life
um the why increases I think I might be
disciplined with that but where I sit
today I go
I'm
I'm a little bit overextended
but there's no part of me that would see
taking a month off as
helpful or necessary so
I would you see what I'm saying
I you know that at Christmas time I take
about three weeks and I go to Bali I've
done that Costa Rica and Bali every year
for the last three years there I I sit
alone and I write that's what I would do
in my free time I wouldn't enjoy
taking a month off and doing nothing
my stability is chaos yeah my chaos is
now it is
always been nowadays
um but the discomfort uh that comes up
for you around the idea of doing nothing
I think is worthy of Investigation 100
yeah and maybe you do need to burn out
maybe or something has to happen for you
to recognize that I just think that
under universal law you have stress and
rest right you go to the gym you stress
your body you rest you recover you go to
sleep every night everything is a cycle
whether it's a micro cycle or a macro
cycle so you know that you I know that
you prioritize sleep
you don't set an alarm you make sure
that you get as much sleep as you need
so that you can be the high performer
that you are that's in the micro but in
the macro look at it from a decade
perspective or an annual perspective you
need to build in those rest intervals
just the same this is why my girlfriend
is such a great counterbalance in my
life because she demands of me my time
when we go away so we went away to
Portugal but how dare she do that yeah I
know I'm saying that really badly but
everything in my life is is uh I do I do
because I want to do and when she says I
want to go to Portugal for a week and
spend some time with my family I wanted
I want to go as well it's not and I say
this to it she knows this about me
if she wasn't out I wouldn't be doing
this
like if she wasn't in my life default
Steve when she goes away herself for two
weeks is intense
really really intense
and I like it yeah I know this
is
I understand this but I but I also
reflect and go it's not
it's not sustainable and there's this
other thing that's about to imagine my
life which is children at some point in
the next three years
how will I fit children into that
equation when they will also demanded me
my attention to my time something's got
to give and as always I found in some of
my friends
when they're not changing behaviors and
they're not breaking habits maybe they
just need a little bit more pain
and it's a horrible thing to say but you
know that
um certain people just need a little bit
more pain before they change course and
say enough is enough maybe I need a
little bit more pain in the opposite
direction to flip my incentive structure
um but I have to also caveat this by
saying I'm happy
whatever that means
as in I wake up with a deep sense of
gratitude for the life that I get to
live and
um
I rarely have
sad days I mean can I think of having a
sad day I've had like really difficult
periods but I don't have a lot of sad
days
um
so yeah that's also why there's not been
enough force in the opposite direction
getting me to change the way I am yeah I
mean I'm glad to hear that you're happy
and I think that's genuine I believe you
but I I think there's a
maybe just beneath the surface some
control issues some fear around what it
would feel like what it would look like
if you had to kind of release the reins
a little bit and let some other people
in that's very threatening to your
identity and the direction that you're
driving your ship right now I think
you're scary I think you I think you've
nailed it
maybe I'm not so conscious of that fear
but I think there's definitely a fear
there because why wouldn't I go in and
hang out in
um beautiful places around the world and
beaches and just relax and just get on
the moped and just drive down go to the
gym and just chill out and just do
something else and not be obsessed why
wouldn't I do that where does this
Obsession come from and it is it's an
obsession my team know it's a seven day
a week shower walking down the street
everywhere I go obsession
why
I
I would have to relate it to the things
I've said in my childhood and I think
what that created in me is also this
this when you believe you're really
capable of a lot of things when you
really believe in yourself you're almost
haunted by that potential and you always
feel like
there is no end to where you can go and
when you're stood in the face of a huge
perception of potential like you just
think that there's there's no Finish
Line here
um
and I think maybe there's part of me
that thinks myself maybe at a deep level
that thinks my self-esteem is related is
correlated to how far down that
never-ending track I am
and what is the role that your ego is
playing in all of that because there is
a there's a kernel of narcissism at the
center of that thinking that you're the
you're the Puppeteer in charge of all
this latent potential awaiting
manifestation and it's just it's up to
you and your sheer force of will to make
it happen
um and there's something beautiful about
it too I don't want to cast it in in a
pejorative way but what is what when you
say ego how do you define that because
the word is used so broadly sure the
idea that that you and you alone
uh are responsible for whether or not
these great gifts that you're going to
bestow upon the world are going to
happen or not yeah and as such going to
the gym and chilling out and riding a
moped around Bali is a frivolous Pursuit
uh that is reserved for Mortals so I do
believe that I definitely have a bias
towards believing no I do I definitely
have a bias towards believing that my
outcomes in life are like heavily
correlated to what I do
and that can be a gift and a curse you
know the exact way you've just described
it and and what is the relationship
between
self-esteem or just uh you know a
feeling of of Goodwill within yourself
and the external results of of your
labor
this is something that I'm I've had to
Hazard a guess at because it's not
abundantly clear to me but when I think
about
um when I think when I piece together
certain pieces of the jigsaw I can see I
assume that the missing pieces that I
can't see are telling me that there's a
correlation between what I achieve and
my perception of myself at a deep level
you know I can't fully see that picture
but there must be
um
and yeah this is something that I suffer
from yeah so I can relate to this
self-inquiry but I know that you've
shared
your kind of ongoing conversation with
yourself around this that perhaps was
maybe initially prompted when you sat
with Rodney Swami oh yeah and he said
something to you yeah around the idea of
of you being enough or yeah
um you are loved for who you are and and
you're kind of recoiling response to
that yeah so
um
that conversation actually came from a
lady that came to my office and said to
my team many years ago just imagine
you're already enough imagine that you
have everything you need and you've all
these goals that you have in your life
they don't actually matter you already
have everything you need and I remember
thinking that's a lot of nonsense God
that's gonna mean that what's the point
getting out of bed in the morning what's
the point of motivation if you've if
you're already enough remember walking
back to my desk the idea sat in my brain
for two years and everything I figured
out about the nature of my life proved
it to be true and also when I realized
that at 25 when I got that range of a
million pound six-pack girlfriend and
the anti-climactic feeling of
you aiming at the wrong thing and none
of these goals ever mattered made me
realize that unless you believe what
that woman said to me that day unless
you believe that you are currently
already enough
what ends up happening is you fall into
the Trap of thinking that one Steve
Bartlett can be worth more than one
Steve Bartlett if I accomplish something
the currency of Steve Bartley's one
Steve Bartlett irrespective of
accomplishment is always going to be
worth the same inside here so if I
reject if I accept this idea
that I'm already enough and that none of
this stuff is going to move me then I
can start aiming at things that I didn't
believe would sway my internal worth
which means aiming at internal Ambitions
intrinsic things which is why the
podcast really took off and why I
started it because it was something I
would do regardless of um
regardless of remuneration
um so one of the things in my life that
I loved obviously the motivation
structures changed when it becomes a bit
more widely listening sure sure but what
you're getting at really is this idea
this distinction between
ambition
security yeah how how how you mask
insecurity as ambition and it's only in
success that you realize
the nature of that yeah I thought her
words would erode my ambition
in fact it erodes your fake Ambitions
what it illuminates is your real
Ambitions and um and I have kids come up
to me after I speak on stage and I'll
say I want to be a public speaker like
19 year old kids and I go why do you
want to be a public speaker and they go
you know like I wanna I wanna I wanna
speak on stage what they're actually
doing what they actually want is they
want the admiration they just saw you
get right it's not that they have an
idea they feel compelled to share it's
about you it's about standing on a stage
and having people look at them and and
clap which they didn't get at seven
years old so that's a fake ambition they
don't actually want to be a public
speaker
um and in that instance we've confused
aspiration with admiration
um we have admiration for what we just
saw in that person so we think it's an
aspiration of our own but they're two
very different things and
so yeah that changed my life but the
rump I can't even pronounce his name
what he said to me was in New York Jay
Shetty took me to his conference when I
was 20 something early 20s and I was
contending with this internal issue
where I knew I was really capable of
doing things I knew I was capable of
having an idea and making it happen so I
when I got to ask him a question I said
am I wrong for spending my life building
businesses and enriching myself versus
going to Africa and saving just one life
in the village in Africa where I was
born and he said you can't pour out for
others that which you don't have
yourself
which um which is really eye-opening for
me and so I spent the next 10 years kind
of focusing a lot on building up my
skill set
so that now hopefully I have more that I
can pour out for other people because we
all contend with that feeling don't we
yeah yeah in AAA they say something
similar which is you you cannot transmit
something you haven't got yes which
speaks to the authenticity fake
authenticity thing right if you're
holding yourself out
um in a certain way in the world
and doing it in service of others if
that's not real it's not going to
connect or resonate amen yeah versus
earned experience over time right amen
but when you talk about these these
ideas
um that are a little bit more
ephemeral ethereal
um it reminds me of of a conversation I
had recently with Arthur Brooks uh
social scientist professor at Harvard
Business School and Harvard Kennedy
School
um
he's written a couple books he has a new
book coming out that he co-wrote with
Oprah and he's sort of an expert on
happiness he writes for the Atlantic
magazine and he's distilled The Pursuit
of Happiness down to these four pillars
which are family
friendship work preferably work that is
in service of others or about something
larger than yourself and the final one
being Faith now he's a hardcore Catholic
but
he feels very strongly and the the
social science supports this idea that
if you want true happiness and happiness
not being
a state but rather the result of how you
invest your attention time and energy
that
something Transcendent has to be an
aspect
of that Pursuit
something that is about more than
yourself something that is about through
your work serving others of course and
yet
um
a little more ethereal than that
and I think this is where the rubber
just might hit the road with you right
thank you
as you tense up yeah I was trying to
find find that in my own life the the
closest thing I can get to that is just
the um
conversations you have with people about
how
um
what you do has helped them in some way
that feels like an almost spiritual
um it's the fourth part of the vehicle
yeah right and I think that's why of all
the successes that you've had and all
the things that you've done why the
podcast I think is probably the most
meaningful
100 yeah you know the guy thing the sure
the that fourth piece of doing something
that helps the world or other people
it's the only thing I've ever done in my
life where I've managed to find that
fourth piece done things that I'm good
at that you know will make you money
um but but finding that fourth piece of
like
this is why it's the of all the things I
do in my life it's the most enjoyable
and also like I hate to say it but
it's the least profitable financially
but it's the thing I give most of my
time to when you find that Pursuit
that
is also an offering but is a passion
like it's something you love you would
do ordinarily yeah without compensation
um because it it brings so much meaning
into your own life and then in turn to
have that be of tremendous value to
other people is the greatest gift and
it's why I will always do this like I
just love it I would do it I would do it
for free I did do it for free for many
years I'm very grateful that um it
supports my family now but I understand
that
um impulse and I'm that's why I'm not
surprised despite all of the companies
and all the other things that you do
that that this is the thing that means
the most to you but I still think that
that falls under what Arthur Brooks
would call the work bucket and not the
the faith or Transcendent bucket I grew
up believing in a God I grew up
believing in a higher power and for
whatever reason at 18 years old I was
the last one to
renounce my faith and my family of my
siblings for whatever reason I
discovered the work of Richard Dawkins
and Sam Harris and
Hitchens and I start to question as I do
with a lot of things I decided to I had
these new ideas in my head so I spent
two years as this absolutely obsessed
atheist agnostic reading every book
watching every documentary in all of my
free time and from there my faith my
faith fell away but um I find faith in
and or in Beauty in
the stars and the universe and all of I
spend so long reading and studying about
the universe and watching the cosmos
documentaries and that has become my new
ore which is this incredible
um The Ore of the world we live in and
it almost came to a point in my life
where I didn't feel like I needed to
believe in a God or a deity or anything
like that because I can believe in
there's so much awe that my brain can't
understand when I think about a whale I
was talking to my girlfriend about it
last night as we were falling asleep
these things are just awe-inspiring
enough for me to you know and there's so
many unanswered questions so I have to
live in would you call it Faith or would
you would you call it just uncertainty
around the nature of why I'm here and
what I'm doing what the real game is of
life
[Music]
um yeah I think uncertainty and and
being able to inhabit
um a place of awe and wonder I think is
a gateway drug towards something greater
but I think in that process a big piece
of it is developing
a capacity for humility that can act as
a counterweight Against The Wiles of the
ego that are luring you in in in
directions quite attractive but
ultimately not in your long-term best
interest the the recurring Trend I've
noticed in the guests that I've had on
that I've been through AAA so recently
Russell Brand rain Wilson those friends
both friends both written books about
spirituality both told me they said what
you've just said to me about the faith
being such an instrumental part of their
lives to the point that I think Russell
alluded to the fact that without faith
he is he would not be able to
be stable in his day-to-day I think he
said something to me like I spend the
first two hours of the day reconnecting
to my faith just so I can be normal
and I noticed that my guests who have
been through AAA are the ones that
really
um have
spoken to me so passionate about the
importance of faith is am I like seeing
something here is there a correlation
with that well a is a spiritual program
right so it is one of the one of the
principles in one of the steps is is
developing uh uh and understanding and
appreciation of a god of your own
understanding a higher power uh and and
the steps are really rooted in
ancient spiritual Traditions that are
tried and true around doing a personal
inventory and making amends you know
from almost a karmic perspective
meditation is one of the steps being of
service giving back humility all of
these things Infuse uh that 12-step
program but fundamentally it is about
surrendering your life and your will and
your power over to something greater
than yourself and what is that that idea
of surrender I think is very
counterintuitive and and particularly
with people who are
um of the kind of alpha personality
types because it provokes a sense of of
giving up in them which I have only
learned over the years is an illusion
the idea being that
when you're in
your own self-will and you're running
your life according to those parameters
where it's all about you and what you
want and what you need and it's up to
you to get it
um that that can be an effective fuel
source that can even reap positive
rewards in your life but but it will
ultimately plateau and hold you back
from your greatest capacity which is
what happens when you allow yourself to
recede a little bit more into the
background relinquish those reins and
understand that there are forces greater
than yourself at work and at Play
that when you can be in that space will
help guide you in the direction you're
meant to go and I think
the entry point for you is making the
connection between that and this very
strong
sense of self and intuition that you
have that has always been your guiding
force in your life what is that
force or faith for you
it's undefined you know it doesn't fall
into any specific tradition other than
kind of a broad knowing that there are
that there are forces at play that are
beyond our capacity to intellectually
understand and it's my job to not be in
engaged in trying to understand it with
my mind and instead to let go of that
and just engage with the heart which
means paying attention to that inner
voice what is it telling me
why do I have this where does that come
from
and really respecting that which I think
you already do
okay but but you don't have to do a
practice like a daily practice to
connect with that well that's of your
own design but I think a practice around
Stillness and quietude so that you can
hear
what's being said inside of you I think
is important and again I think this is
something that you're already doing
but I think that's why meditation and
mindfulness practices can be so powerful
because they connect you with that hard
voice that's so easy to cloud in the
Gestalt of our busy stressful lives
you're completely right because the
person I know your girlfriend what's
your girlfriend's name again Melanie
Melanie yeah I mean I'm sure she would
she's probably banging this drum in your
ear all day long
you would no no she's living it yeah but
she's she I mean she wakes up and
meditates for an hour every single
morning and where she's liberated from
the need for you to see it the way that
she does yeah which is which is evidence
of an advanced consciousness
but it goes both ways as well like we
it's really interesting to have a
girlfriend who's so deeply spiritual
that's her career that's her life she
does Retreats breath work Studio where
we met yesterday
but the reason why we work is because we
have our lives and we're securing it and
we're not trying to convert the other
individual to our way of thinking we're
looking over and stealing things from
each other's lives we said this in the
car two days ago she was like I love I
used to think I wanted to be with
someone who was also really really
spiritual but I've got that box ticked
so being with you allows me to learn
something and vice versa in terms of
I've learned so much from her from just
observing her
um it's really interesting though
because when I do go to Bali at the end
of the year the conversation in my head
and who I am is much closer to who I
want to be and it's because of this the
Stillness it's because I've I've had
space
away from the machine so can you bring
some piece of that into your daily
life and a routine
I have sat with so many amazing people
super successful people that I love and
admire so much who tell me about the
importance of meditation
and I have still not
made it a habit in my life a discipline
in my life
and again it's because there's something
in my brain and this is me just being
completely honest I completely believe
in meditation and Stillness and taking
30 minutes a day even you know 20
minutes a day I completely believe in
how much that would impact my life
do you though
but because you are so good at taking
those things you know will benefit you
and incorporating them into your life
yeah the resistance there I think is
interesting because I think on some
level you do believe but there is also a
big part of you that doesn't
the
the part of the discipline equation now
that I think about that it's missing is
prioritization comes into play because
your time is a zerosome game yeah so it
depends if I believe in deep within me
if I believe something else is going to
reap a greater return on investment so
you can believe these things I can I
believe meditation is important just
because I've heard it so much I've
experienced it in my own life a little
bit but I think somewhere in me I
believe all these other things are more
important I believe getting up at 9am
and having that call with the fund
manager who's going to invest in our
fund was more important than pausing for
30 minutes and until the prioritization
um changes it won't happen
is that is that accurate does that make
sense like am I am I yeah or am I bsing
myself uh I don't know only you know
yeah because there's some things I
believe and I want to do but they're not
winning out over the other thing sure I
think part of it is is
this idea that you know our morning
routines are now extended you know hours
and hours and hours like what are you
gonna actually do
to begin your day are you going to get
up you're not going to set the alarm so
you're going to wake up later so you get
your rest and then you're going to do
your meditation and then you're going to
do your cold plunge and your sauna and
your workout and your your morning pages
and your journaling it's one o'clock in
the afternoon
yeah so I understand that there's
something very human about that but I
think it's curious I mean you recently
had Sam Harris on the podcast you've had
Russell you've had all these people
they're they're you know I mean Sam
atheist right so he's non-threatening to
you from that kind of uh organized
religion perspective or or spirituality
perspective and yet I think he would
aggressively uh advise you that that 30
minute meditation is far more important
than these other things that your brain
is telling you
um should come first
I look at it through the context of that
discipline equation and I say okay
friction's probably quite High because
it's difficult for me to sit down and do
nothing that's quite a difficult
psychological challenge for me the
enjoyment of it is probably not high
enough and the why is probably not clear
enough
so if something happens in my life if I
have some kind of experience maybe I go
on a retreat and someone sits with me
for seven days and they really show me
that needs to be I need to feel it and
see it for myself how transformative
this is and they they find some way to
make it more enjoyable for me and reduce
the friction it will stick sleep is a
really interesting
example of this how it's stuck in my
life last night before I went to bed I
kissed my girlfriend on the lips I said
last night babe my sleep efficiency was
really really low so I'm gonna sleep in
the spare room tonight which is my room
and I slept in the room I wake up first
thing in the morning look at my week
check exactly how much sleep I've had
because
I ran the experiment of not sleeping and
sleeping and saw the variants using data
to understand the correlation in my mood
performance and how I feel is so great
when I'm when I haven't had restorative
sleep that it it's stuck and now it's
like a non-negotiable in my life and
meditation will have to do the same
thing it will have to impress upon me so
greatly the advantages of it that that Y
part will become discipline
it's it's not there yet with me and does
that have to be experiential I think so
could you take the advice of of people
who are practitioners of this who could
tell you trusted people yeah people like
Sam Harris Tim Ferriss people like that
that you know you probably on some level
uh you know uh appreciate their wisdom
and and believe that they're credible
and what they're telling you
so they they've all told me
see this is the things the beliefs right
yeah yeah you talk about with beliefs
it's interesting too you're like I could
see the gears in your brain working you
have this mental model and you're trying
to solve it intellectually
I I believe that our beliefs are most
significantly influenced by our first
party experiences and that's why I talk
about running these experiments and
building self-belief if you try and have
a conversation with a flat earther you
can tell them all that you can show them
pictures the whole thing in the book
about this yeah yeah the only way you
would ever convert Flat Earth is taking
them up there that's the only way taking
up there and looking at looking at the
planet that's the only way I there
probably would be another
reason they would come up with
oh yeah when they got up yeah they would
say oh this is an illusion but that's
the closest you could do and it's the
same with climate change until people
see the river in their own their own
village overflowing every single week
they're not gonna see a gradual change
happening in the atmosphere they won't
believe it so the same I think applies
for all of us when we're trying to
change our beliefs you have to go and
get first party evidence that you
subjectively accept as true and I can
expose you to first party evidence but
you might not subjectively accept it's
true so you have to then accept that
it's true
breath work was a good example for me my
girlfriend did took me to a breath work
class
breath work what breathing and I had a
really transformative experience where
I'm crying after
I believe in breath work yeah holotropic
breathing yeah yeah yeah yeah that kind
of like psychedelic yeah it's incredibly
powerful you can get a group of people
to open up and weep and share
experiences almost instantaneously
people that don't even know each other
so my wife takes groups of people
through this exercise on our Retreats
and it bonds the group and it's amazing
what people share in the aftermath of
these experiences it's like a
psychedelic experience without taking
psychedelics do you think we've all got
a different sort of barometer of
skepticism and a requirement for logic
and proven evidence and science when we
approach Our Lives because I use talking
about the cogs going on in my brain I'm
definitely someone that needs to see it
sure
and understand the science for me to
accept it yeah
get over yourself is that is that really
yeah I think I think on some level I
understand it because I'm the same way
and my relationship feels uh to my wife
feels similar to your relationship with
your girlfriend even though I haven't
met her just based on what you've shared
with me and I think
I am best guided when I'm able to kind
of step out the step outside of the
confines understand that that
our brains are attempting to identify
patterns that help us make sense of the
world
and we do that so that we feel safe this
understanding of who we are this crafted
identity that I know I'm very invested
in
um based upon these mental models that I
have about how the world Works about who
I am and how I fit into it and I think
some of my greatest growth has been
when I can
disabuse myself
of those parameters or understand their
limitations and just allow myself to
step outside of it and entertain
something different and I think what's
interesting about this
given your resistance but also your
curiosity is this disposition that you
have around questioning the question
like this is almost a gift of yours to
always try to step outside whatever
Paradigm you're in so that you can
have a broader view of what is happening
and and identify a different or new way
so maybe for you questioning the
question
should be applied to your own
pattern making capacity in your
intellectual mind part of me the way I
like rationalize it to myself and this
might not be true is if I accept things
that I can't
understand or see the data on or
experience then I'm susceptible to
accepting anything and that's not that
doesn't feel like a productive framework
for decision making as I proceed in my
life and I have to be honest this might
have been influenced by
my early contacts because you've got a
mother who will believe everything
and then seeing that fail her everything
things with no evidence you know I would
wake up and she would have my 3am in the
morning she's got my maths books from
school and she's going through them to
find numbers she's got a ball spinning
here and she's finding numbers in the in
the math book putting her finger on them
and if they come out of this ball that
she's spinning she'll play them in the
lottery um
yeah I understand she put an egg on my
head when I wake up in the morning and
be doing smoke in my room so I saw this
like superstitious
you know and we all all four of us are
the most pragmatic I mean mathematicians
pragmatic we require data to believe
things and we rejected that right as a
reaction I think so yeah it was just so
strange to us so we've all gone up grown
up to be very logical and evidence-based
every single one of us and uh I've
applied that to my life clearly where
I'm super skeptical about things and yet
you found your way to Melanie yeah who
sees the world very differently and
navigates it differently than you and
there's something about that that that
clearly is intriguing and interesting
and compelling every girlfriend is like
that yeah every girlfriend I've had is
like that right right so what is that
I think it's I mean maybe there's like
Freudian mother yeah yeah
I am also a really really curious person
you've outsourced your R and wonder yes
your partner 100 that's why I said which
makes you feel safe while also
appreciating it as long as it is at
arm's length yeah and as long as it's
not
trying to convert it's not threatening
your your yeah your your mental model I
love it I would not be with I said to
her you last two days ago when we're in
the car talking about this notice how
I've never dated anyone like myself I
said that would be a nightmare I love
being able to look into your world in
your window and and see how you you're
doing the investigations for me you're
rummaging around and then you're telling
me about it but you're not trying to
convert me you're sharing and from that
I've taken things I've become a way
better person because of that and that
non-threatening way like she's not
threatening to me she's not trying to
convert me to anything so it's been a
wonderful balance in my life having her
um both for work-life balance or
whatever they call it but also for like
spiritual balance and she'll notice in
me she's noticed a huge change in me
since she met me it's just slower my
girlfriend and I say this with all
respect she defaults to accepting
new ideas and beliefs
about the world I default to
interrogation and pessimism
and one or two of them get in but they
get in slowly and after meeting certain
characters they have to be they're sort
of stress tested for you a lot of men
100 like breath work I don't know what
the science says about it but you've had
an experience with it it doesn't matter
the sounds to me I mean the guy
explained it to me and that's probably
why he was the right person to do it
with me he explained the physiological
processes in my body with vital flight
and
how we live in a state of shallow
breathing and how the oxygen in the
brain and then we did the session
I've so you have explanation you have
experience acceptance yeah for me yeah
you can't just give me an explanation
yeah
um you have an interesting relationship
with risk uh for you the risk would be
to live an ordinary life
um to extend yourself and and you know
kind of pursue these startups doesn't
feel like a risk to you in the way that
it would maybe for somebody who's wired
a little bit differently so I'm curious
around
what you feel to be risky or what is it
that that
is luring you in a certain direction but
frightens you and feels like a risk even
though
you know perhaps it's something you
should explore
um the thing that frightens me I think
if I'm being honest
is as the platform that I have like with
the diary Macio has gotten bigger with
that comes just more feedback to deal
with ghost kind of goes back to what I
was saying about rejection and that kid
in the playground in school
your six your success which you you
drive towards because you want
validation you want clapping right also
comes with booing and I think that is
the thing that frightens me like I I
know that in order to have a happy life
going forward what I need is a small
context of people that I love that are
around me and to be doing things for
intrinsic reasons but as that expands
the temptation to tune into external
voices or to do things that aren't
intrinsic increases and that is the risk
that I face in my life being swayed away
from myself and into
um caring about the noise that I've
clearly been intentional in trying to
create does that make sense yeah yeah
that's the thing that terrifies me yeah
how that might hurt my life like I one
of the things I'm scared of is like
people knowing who my girlfriend is
and how that might ruin this special
part of my life that is keeping is
really pure and wonderful and small and
feels like a you know I'm scared of that
you know Rogan's managed that really
really well because people don't really
keeps that out of it yeah he seems very
conscious around
um what he's willing to share about his
personal life but I think that's the
trade-off right you're in the public
sphere and it comes with a good and it
comes with the bad
um
but can you
rest your head every night knowing that
you put out content
that is attempting to raise the
vibration of Consciousness like you you
you truly are approaching this from a
place of curiosity and genuine interest
to learn and to share
um good ideas with people and maybe not
every episode is going to connect with
everybody in the way that you
um would like but I think intention
matters and I think it's very clear
uh the intention that you're bringing to
what it is that you're doing
and I guess what I would say is with
that irrespective of what the cackling
and the caucus is around whatever
episode or whatever's happening that's
outside of your control can you not just
sleep easy knowing that you did your
best to do good in the world
yeah 90 95 of times so then what what
trips you up
that you know it would be
this is why I try not to expose myself
too broadly it would be
some kind of external I'm new to being
in a public eye
so I haven't put the systems in place
everywhere yet to dealing with that
I've over the last six 12 months made a
lot of progress but I went from being
someone that people really didn't know
at all to being on the num like the
number one business show in the UK
called Dragon's Den which is like Shark
Tank in America
um being a dragon on there and the
podcast in correlation to that resurging
in the country to being the most
downloaded in arm
in our country and that suddenly thrust
me to the front and I didn't have
systems in place to deal with that which
meant that like walking down the street
in shoreditch
there's a reporter following in the car
taking photos of me and my girlfriend
walking down the street then publishing
those and saying things that aren't true
about we were walking to the gym we were
on our way back from the gym the
pictures in the newspapers say like
having a Corral yeah like a heartbreak
he's like gotten back with his
girlfriend after she she dumped him for
work over working now when you receive
that the brain is not doesn't know how
to process that yeah if just if trying
if you try and process that without
conscious Consciousness and
intentionality so how do I handle those
those that information and feedback in a
way that will allow me to remain focused
on what matters in my life that's what
I've been working on for the last two
years and I think I've made a lot of
good progress if I'm honest to put those
systems in place but as you Propel
further further into the public eye
because your show's growing hugely my
show grows what what comes next you know
I look at other people who are further
down the line I look at some of the
stuff that like a Rogan has been through
and I go man I don't wish I don't wish
that on anybody and I and I wouldn't
like to to endure what you know like a
version of what you just shared I feel
like right now I'm in this sort of
perfect place where occasionally people
say hi to me but it's always nice and it
isn't invasive into my life and and I'm
very cautious about it morphing into
anything more unmanageable than that
the only reason it did for me was
because I went onto a show which is like
an institution in our country yeah like
so if you go and if I think if I was
doing my podcast it wouldn't be the case
if it's the minute that I went into that
world
the traditional media world yeah that's
when it all changed for me before then I
didn't have this I didn't have this
issue no one cared about me no one
wanted to write anything about me or
talk about me
um and I almost you know it's
interesting Rogan is obviously so big
that he is he's in everything it's a
different thing yeah yeah so and he's
also a UFC and you know everything he's
done on TV so
so you have this new book
um The Diary of a CEO which I really
enjoyed I was sharing with you
um
yesterday on the street about it on the
one hand
it's really chock full of all kinds of
Timeless wisdom it's definitely written
with an eye towards it being timeless it
doesn't matter that it's 2023 or what
year it is but also in a way that's
quite Breezy and easy to digest and read
uh with Recaps and it's sort of written
with an eye towards grabbing attention
holding attention and and keeping it as
lean as possible like there's no extra
words here you say exactly what you need
to say in order to drive your point home
and to support it with studies or
examples of people that you've had on
the podcast and I think you did a really
wonderful job and it's going to impact a
lot of people but I'm curious around why
you decided to write a book we were
talking yesterday and I was saying yeah
you can spend two years writing a book
uh it will make less money than doing a
podcast it will reach less people like
the in your mental model of running the
equation of you know value and
investment of time resources Etc how do
you come out squaring that equation on
the side of of you know investing the
time and energy required to put
something out that's good
there's so much to be gained in the
unobvious decision throughout this
conversation we've talked about how when
sort of inauthenticity was high there
was this counter movement towards
authenticity and now there's like
another counter movement which is like
fake authenticity when digital music
came along you know
vinyls surged again now that we've
become more glued to screens and phones
IRL community
things are surging you even see bowling
alleys being making a comeback and
miniature golf and all these things and
I believe the same about pickleball yeah
all of these things that are coming back
and it's I I love it so much because I
bet on humans innate desire for
connection and being together in a world
where everyone's optimizing in the other
direction it will always be there so
there's a big opportunity there to bring
people together last night we actually
did a dinner party for direvacion
listeners third one we've done there's
nothing more magical that we've ever
done as a team there's nothing where
people
won't leave the room 20 total strangers
from our community that stand up they
all have question cards in front of them
from the podcast they reveal something
deeply intimate about them vulnerable
about them those 20 people become best
friends that night they they literally
best friends they make WhatsApp groups
together and then their friends for like
since the last one we've done they've
been meeting up recurringly there's
something so beautiful about the
unobvious polar opposite
um path there's Wonder there and that's
kind of how I see a book I spend all my
time making content Instagram quotes and
podcasts and the Wonder I found in
something both physical
um
that has such depth that takes so long
to write
is hard to articulate but it was it's
the most enjoyable thing to me when
a couple hundred thousand people whoever
or however many that buy that book read
that focus on it and then have a
conversation with me about it it's way
more impactful than the Facebook video I
did I did 30 million views that was just
a quick cheap viral video three minutes
long
um that did a big number but in terms of
meaning
didn't mean anything to anyone books are
depth they're meaning and they're um
they're considered there's no comment
section
you know yeah yeah he's so special yeah
it's indelible
um and and Lasting in in a in a culture
that's increasingly
um recycled yeah there is a there is a
there is still a sense of permanence
around writing books exactly and it
makes no sense to it makes no sense if
you if you score it based on the
traditional scoring system like you did
like money time it takes reach
but it makes all the sense when you
score it based on
fulfillment for me to write it
fulfillment for the people that take the
time to complete the book
um and as you say enduring because
social media and all these other mediums
are fairly ephemeral
this is the antithesis of that there's
usually value in the antithesis that's
what I've come to learn in my life
so if somebody's listening or watching
this and they're thinking I'm not a
business person I have no desire to be a
CEO I don't even know any CEOs except
maybe my boss like why should I read
this book and you know I have a lot of
reasons that I could speak to about that
but
um I want to hear from you like the
average person picking this up Diary of
a CEO I'm not a business person I'm not
a
any of those things I consider myself to
be
a guy who's trying to
live the best life I can and who's
conducted experiments over the last 15
years to understanding exactly what you
described um
to understanding which laws and
principles will get me closer to living
the life I want to live and I think
that's what this book is largely it's
these 33 principles that have been hard
fought through experimentation in my
life relating to yourself towards being
happy towards having good relationships
towards knowing how to communicate with
another human being towards how to tell
stories to understanding the
psychological biases that are at force
in all of our Lives making us choose
Apple over Samsung or Uber over Lyft or
whatever it is understanding why humans
do what they do including yourself is
really the nature of this book and it
allows you to understand your team
members yourself your customers and all
of those things so yeah it's me it's a
social psychology book really more than
anything and the first third of it is
really about the self yeah this idea
that you can't be a leader or run an
organization if you're not first tending
to Your Vessel and you discuss all the
various ways in which you've done that
or things you've learned as a result of
of hosting the podcast about that but
that's the fundamental pillar upon which
everything else rests can I ask you a
question because you're a very smart
person and I know you've actually read
the book so
what law was stood out to you
I've never had any feedback on the book
have it before because you're one of the
first to read it well I think that that
uh I mean certainly there's plenty in
there that I already knew or I maybe I
didn't have words for but I already kind
of understood uh the idea that uh you
know knowledge is the best uh investment
of your energy and that everything is
built upon from their skill
relationships Network Etc I really love
that idea the one percent kind of gave
it brailles Ford rule who's the British
cycling team Sky guy I love that the
idea of of success being measured in
progress rather than results like being
in this persistent state of moving in a
certain direction is actually more
meaningful than achieving goals or or
um you know hitting benchmarks it's that
sense of we're going somewhere and we're
doing it together I found to be
um really interesting and powerful and
then all this sort of marketing stuff
that I don't know about like why the
Apple store is the way it is and and why
that works creating this
um you know first allowing you to touch
the products and having a sense of
ownership over them and the kind of
luxury scarcity notion of space to
product ratio that exists there and the
examples that you gave
um around creating friction between the
customer and the product I thought was
something I hadn't heard of with the
cake mix and yeah yeah you know it
wasn't working when it was so easy until
they realized that and said okay now you
have to add an egg and suddenly sales
were more like all these weird kind of
counter-intuitive marketing things that
then you go on to describe how you apply
them in your podcast was personally
relevant to me because I was like wait
he does what like you know I'm reading
this book I joke with you yesterday I'm
going to make everyone on my team read
this I'm like all these like like this
is some crazy Machiavellian
that he's doing this podcast that's
making it grow and like we're looking at
YouTube trying to figure out like what
are we missing here or what I don't I'll
put out amazing content and sometimes
it's flat on YouTube and I don't know
what I'm doing and I see you with this
hockey stick growth right now and then I
read the book and I realize like oh the
level of intentionality the attention to
detail all these things that I really
appreciate that aren't you know like
great Mysteries it's like you really
care about what you do you've hired
really good skilled people you stay up
late with them and you pay attention to
the small details the things that um
other people don't care about that
become the differentiator and that's
something that that I believe in and I
thought that I was doing until I read
the book and realized like oh this guy's
at a whole other level like the
story that you tell about when the
guests come in to the studio you do
enough research to play the music that
they like like your favorite music and
not one guest has ever mentioned it no
but the idea that you think that that's
important as a detail and then I was
trying to remember what music you were
playing
[Music]
um
that was super fascinating because
because
I really am proud of the fact that I
think that we're executing at a very
high level on our podcast and then to
realize like oh there's so much more
growth there are so many other things
that I wasn't even thinking about
um and credit to you know the success
that you're that you're having with the
show right now but I don't think
I think those details are all super
important but I think they speak to
a broader commitment and intentionality
that you're bringing to the
conversations and I think that's the
real mover in why your show is doing so
well and connecting with so many people
so it's none of those Details Matter
unless the conversation itself is
special the conversation itself is the
part that I feel like I haven't
um ran any experiments on that because
it's just led by curiosity so when you
walk in the door
there's no data that's going to tell me
what to speak to you about it's what I'm
interested in about in this individual
outside of that the process undergoes a
lot of experimentation and one percent
searching but the conversation is like
like I said with Simon sinek where he
comes and sits down and says I'm lonely
I'm gonna ask I'm gonna ask him the
questions I care about I've actually
never written a question down I have
bullet points of dates and stuff but
I've never in my my own you want to see
my outline this is like I do the same
thing they're not questions they're just
they're ideas right but I think this
this is interesting because this goes to
what we were talking about earlier the
The Head and the Heart the head wants to
say here's the architecture for a
perfect conversation here's how I'm
going to do it I'm going to start with
the Mr Beast five second how do I grab
them well I'll go on YouTube I'll look
at all the videos this person has done
and when I see those Peaks I know that's
what people are most interested in so
I'm going to come out of the gate and
ask that question first
that's all good I'm not saying that
doesn't work but truthfully the art of
the conversation is a heart-centered
thing right are you present are you
listening are you sticking to an outline
or are you actually paying attention to
what the person is saying so that you
can have an organic authentic exchange
of ideas and emotions because that's
what moves the needle with people and I
always say when people ask me how do you
approach podcast conversations
you do a lot of prep but then you have
to like an actor you have to put it away
yeah and you have to be willing to go
wherever it wants to lead you and my
goal as a host is to emotionally connect
with the guest if I can do that then I
can trust and have faith that the
conversation will go in the direction
that it's meant to go but when I allow
my head to be in the driver's seat it
ends up being it ends up being flat so
for me it's all about the emotional
connection and I always prided myself on
the guy who could make the guest cry or
evoke you know something
true and special emotionally in the
person that I'm talking to and I see
you as somebody who really understands
that as well and that being at the heart
of what you're trying to do and that's
something that you're not going to solve
with a spreadsheet or a model
so interesting because people say we
we've had a lot of emotion on our show
and in hindsight when you're interviewed
people are trying to ask you how that
happens and so you're trying to figure
it out yourself so you're trying to
apply your head and go well maybe it's
because we do this and this and this and
this and this but it's a hindsight thing
at the end of the day it's because I
genuinely cared about trying to find
something out about them and really
understand that thing and also listening
has actually been the most underrated
thing about our show is like people will
go where they want to go and the longer
you let them go there
the higher probability that they're
going to go to a level they've never
been before you know what I'm saying
yeah but you have to create an
environment that's permissive
for that experience in the way that you
do that is to yes listen but also lead
with vulnerability yourself you can't
expect the guest to open up if they
don't have the sense that you're willing
to meet them there so true
so true yeah and people will say oh
Stephen he's the guy he's the guy who he
wants to know about the trauma like
what's the trauma that made you the
special person that you are yeah and
that's really the I think that's the
sort of skeleton key that unlocks your
approach to your guess if it's important
to say that that's because I genuinely
want to know right I I had a tool and
it's real yeah I had a tour guide for
seven days in Peru first six days he's
talking to me about buildings so I'm not
even honestly I'll be honest I'm not
paying attention to him my girlfriend's
talking to him for those first Six Days
on the seventh day he starts talking
about the variance in happiness and mood
and Trauma that he's seen from all of
these guests that he's taken on the
tours from China to Poland and I am
glued I'm transfixed on him he says to
me at that dinner on the seventh day
when we're parting ways he goes you
didn't care for the first six days about
these buildings you didn't care about
how old this building was the minute I
started talking about people and why
they are the way they are you were like
I was interviewing him what about these
people what about these people are they
more grateful are they happier and that
it was just another instance for me also
I think about my childhood I couldn't
date people because my first questions
were always too deep
so it was a nice filter for me to see if
they were my type of person because I
might ask them straight away a really
deep question about themselves and a lot
of people don't like that my podcast is
a reflection of what I'm interested in I
want to know why people are the way they
are I'd love to interview serial killers
and just to understand
you know what's making them tick under
there so
who is it that you really want to get on
right now do you know one of the people
I want to get on is Elon because
I used to have him on my wall
you know as like an elite entrepreneur
that solved huge problems and is
unlabeled I love people that are
unlabeled like when you said earlier
that I'm a CEO or an entrepreneur I like
see myself as this as a person with a
multitude of interests he's achieved so
much across such a broad range of things
his life is clearly overextended in any
in any measure
I wonder if he's really happy and also
in the last year there's been a bit of a
change in Elon with this whole sweater
thing the way he's speaking online and I
want to get to the heart of why that is
why he's changed he's become a little
bit ugly in his tone sometimes
um in my opinion
and I want to know if he cares about
happiness because I've heard him sound
to Rogan you wouldn't want to be in my
head it's so painful but Rogan didn't
ask more about that sure I would love to
know more about that mm-hmm
yeah what is driving his online Persona
and that erratic Behavior what's fun
what's beneath that what's behind that
what is the need that he's trying to
fill by purchasing Twitter and becoming
this sort of
um
uh you know trolley kind of edgelord
online what does it do it's not
befitting a man of his stature who has
you know really revolutionized industry
and had he not purchased Twitter and
kind of become addicted to you know what
he's doing online
um we would just be in absolute
reverence of this guy and he would have
had a lot more time to pursue you know
changing the world in in meaningful and
positive way and hanging out with his
kids
um
yeah that would be one
I've never seen someone have a
conversation with Elon that I want to
have you would be great to have Elon on
because you would go to the same places
that I think I would want to go yeah but
I think you're somebody who you know I
listen to a lot of old interviews with
you and you talk a lot about Elon and I
and I found myself wondering I was
listening a couple interviews over the
last week that you would that you had
done maybe from like 2020 2021
and and and yes you have a lot of
reverence for what he's achieved and and
his kind of um unique way of thinking
and problem solving and I found myself
wondering like I wonder if you would say
that in 2023 well he's no longer on my
wall
because I don't feel the same way about
him I have huge admiration for the way
he thinks his first principal mindset
which I've completely stolen and all of
these things relating to Innovation
problem solving and also kind of like
getting a lot done yeah but I can't
relate to this guy that I see doing the
memes and the kind of right wingy
some of the rhetoric I just find it
quite ugly and divisive
and I'm trying to square so I'd like to
speak there's a bit of a there I think a
charitable interpretation would be that
he enjoys being a Chaos Agent and
there's a little bit of
um
uh uh a little bit of the twinkle in his
eye like he knows that he's being
provocative and there's something
thrilling about that for him that would
be the most charitable interpretation my
guess is that he did the right thing for
a long time built this car company built
this rocket company
um Tesla changed the automotive industry
it was the Catalyst for laws changing
proving that you could have fast quote
affordable electric cars and then all
the other manufacturers have followed
see he's done really great stuff and he
was attacked and he was attacked
relentlessly and even the president of
the United States when talking about
environmental issues attacked him for
and he's not invited onto their their
like yeah EV you know auto manufacturers
the left have attacked him relentlessly
so he's found a home as he kind of puts
on his own words on the right and as a
way to stop the attacks or take control
over it of all these journalists he
bought Twitter that was the home of the
attacks it was kind of a way to stifle
the attacks now he finds himself over on
the right kind of and
you know I think I think that was it I
think he couldn't comprehend that he was
doing good for good reasons yet these
people were trying to destroy him and
they were trying to destroy him
some of the stories make sense that
makes sense I think on top of that I
would add uh I think he said publicly
that he you know would have liked to
have been a stand-up comic so there's a
part of him there's a little comedian
aspect to that that I think he's trying
to express 100 I don't know no you're
right you won't yeah yeah yeah yeah so
who who's replaced Elon on that wall for
you then you can give me your answer
yeah what you haven't given me your
answer ah
let me think about that
I don't spend a lot of time thinking
about this kind of stuff it's sort of
like you know where do you see yourself
in five years you know what I mean it's
like people think that I have some
answer you know at the ready because I
do get asked this question a lot yeah
and because I'm asked it so often I
should have an answer every time I get
asked it I can't think of anything I
mean the truth is like okay the people
that I'm interested in having I get to
have on you have one interview left oh
God you have to you get one interview
who'd you have it with
there's so many variables that play into
that because you can think of archetypal
individuals who would be amazing but
then you think yeah but is that person
really going to open up to me am I going
to actually get anything interesting out
of that person because they're so media
Savvy or because this is just another
interview so I think the receptivity
piece is really important yeah you know
what I mean like of course it's not
about getting the big name it's about
the person who is ready and it being the
right time for that conversation I think
timing is super important where are they
in their life are they in a place where
they really want to open up in a way
that they haven't before and not
everybody wants to do that most people
don't they have too much to lose and not
enough to gain
so
that's what I think about and I think
about that more than I think about the
person because I think every single
person
could deliver them the the best podcast
I've ever done
and yeah exactly and for me when people
say to you who's your favorite guest
blah blah right and I was asked that in
in the hallway out here just before
coming in and I said what I always say
which is like it's very difficult to
choose but I will say this and I'm
curious how this lands for you I'm still
dodging here yeah
I'll get to it
uh for me the most meaningful guess have
been
relatively Anonymous people maybe not
totally Anonymous but not like big names
but people who just come in and they
have the most amazing story and they
tell it with such earnestness and Pathos
and integrity and honesty and
vulnerability that it ends up touching
people in ways you couldn't have
expected and in turn because of the
scale of the podcast it ends up
impacting their life in a way they
didn't anticipate and changing the
trajectory of what they're doing and and
and impacting people out in the world in
a very meaningful way and so those tend
to be the most personally meaningful and
gratifying guests to have on and they're
not ones that you would know their names
necessarily because so I'm always
looking for those people you help that
person get the credit they deserve sure
you get you have the privilege of
shining a light on somebody who is
deserving of that attention who
otherwise might never have received it
so as fun as it is to have shiny people
on the podcast
the real value for me is in finding
those
nuggets you know that are hidden under
the rocks and maybe living between the
crevices and unearthing them and pushing
them out in front and saying
share
I mean I couldn't add another word to
what you just said
if I had to add a different a different
point my second favorite type of guest I
mean that's definitely it we say this
all the time but my second favorite is
when you think you know someone
because they've been in the public eye
and they've presented a certain image we
had a guy on called Jimmy Carr and he's
a comedian that's known for just
one-liners they usually kind of like
filthy one-liners and he walked in that
day and he was this completely different
person this deep philosophical guy that
spent the whole two hours talking about
what happiness truly is and it shocked
me it shocked our viewers and it's um
was one of the best performing
conversations a totally different
individual to the one you know yeah that
felt really worthwhile yeah yeah
um yeah but that's that's like lightning
striking you know you can't manufacture
that in somebody like it takes two
people and that like it goes back to
what I was saying about timing yeah that
person was in the right mindset at the
right time in their life where they were
willing to share something that perhaps
even weeks earlier
they would have been too afraid to and
something about
the the environment that you're
cultivating and creating that is
conducive to those types of
conversations you have to set a tone
um and and create a space where somebody
feels safe doing that and sometimes it's
hard look we're in here there's cameras
there's lights you're comfortable I'm
comfortable doing this not everybody is
how can you transcend that and get past
that so that the person
um
can be in that in that flow state to
allow that Honesty to come forth
I wish I knew I had a really interesting
conversation with Brian Johnson on my
podcast you know Brian Johnson I've
never met him in person we've had emails
and I know a lot about him and I don't
want to step on your words but I know I
have I have lots of friends who know him
and I think what's interesting about him
is on the surface looking in you would
think well this guy's a weirdo like he
you know he's lost his mind or his
priorities are off but every single
person I know that's spent any time with
him has found him to be incredibly
genuine humble curious and and
well-intentioned with Integrity in what
he's doing and I think it's
cool that he's out there doing that
somebody needs to right so he's like
this Canary in a coal mine who's testing
all of these things for us so anyway I
please you've nailed it it's my team was
saying to me before he arrived at the
studio
um Mark what do you think of him
oh God I don't know and will out there
actually apologize I'm sure we'll won't
mind me saying this will said to me kept
saying to me like what do you think of
that Brian guy God you know and my other
team members were going to what do you
think of that Brian guy and I remember
saying to my team I've not met him yet
I don't know yet
you can read a page six or a daily mail
I'm not interested in that stuff Brian
sat in front of me and presented himself
for two to three hours and in that
conversation I reserved my judgment and
learned about Brian at the end of the
conversation he said something to me
which is the biggest compliment any gas
has ever given to me he goes Steve I go
around and I do lots of these interviews
and I'm very well attuned to little
micro expressions or micro questions
that have that are laced with a kernel
of judgment he goes this last sentence
he says in my podcast you did none of
that
and it was the best compliment I guess
has ever given me because it really
mattered to me that someone who is
clearly so
prejudged before they walk in a room to
do an interview felt that felt safe in
my environment that I there was no ounce
of judgment and it was all curiosity and
I almost got emotional I almost get
emotionally thinking about it now when
he said that because that matters so
much to me
um
and I think that's part of it is like
taking people as not as the the
headlines or the research notes say but
as the person you meet and understanding
that they are human they want love they
want all the things that I want at the
most fundamental level
um and if you I think if you meet them
on that level then you can you can go to
interesting places yeah well I think
that's more profound than how to
approach a podcast conversation because
if you can bring that level of presence
compassion understanding and
non-judgment to your daily interactions
with your friends your family your
co-workers people you meet on the street
uh you will have that same experience I
struggled with that right yeah me too
it's funny
you know it's like it's all performance
and good right yeah can you do that when
you're stuck in traffic or with the
grocery clerk when you're late you know
those are the real moments I struggle
with it particularly with people close
to me in my life where I struggled to
apply the same level of empathy
to the circumstances that might have
made them the way they are and I and I'm
trying to fight with logic to change
them right well the model might be can
you bring that beginner's mind to each
of those exchanges I wish
right I wish uh I beat myself up about
it quite often actually that I'm not
able to apply myself in the way I'd like
to to those situations where someone I
love in my life is exhibiting recurring
behaviors that are self-destructive and
I don't approach it with enough empathy
I approach it with like problem solving
yeah I need to fix you how can I fix you
yeah and I know it's not working how's
that working it's not worked we're eight
you know eight nine years in with
someone like one person in particular
and I've made I've made I probably if
anything I might have made things worse
I think about that too I think the way
I've approached the situation might be
the opposite medicine or antidote to
what they need they might need someone
just to sit in the mud with them Simon
Says usually they do right I think it's
my my wife would call it robbing people
of their Divine moment
oh
if you're trying to fix it if you're
trying to intervene you're interrupting
a process of learning and experience for
that person that perhaps they're better
off experiencing without your
involvement
so you get out the mud or you just see
no you support and you listen and you
say I believe in you to find a solution
for yourself and I'm here for you
rather than here's what you need to do
well that's so hard
especially for someone that has the bias
towards thinking about data and
solutions and evidence and patterns and
you know
something I really struggle with and I I
want to be better because I think I'd
have richer more authentic deeper
relationships if I was able to do that
more often
all right well we got to wrap it up here
but what have we learned we learned that
you're going to be doing
um you're going to go back to your
original format and do some monologuing
that's a promise before the end of the
year did we get an agreement that you're
going to begin a meditation practice
we're not so sure on that I think we've
got the agreement yeah but I think we
we're a little shy of that something
needs to thinking about it I need to go
into Meditation Retreat one of your
Retreats you do this on your Retreats uh
we do yeah when are they uh what's the
next one if we're doing another one I'll
let you know please let me know you're
in Bali all the time you can't throw a
stone yeah
um so we have that what else are we uh
oh
um yeah how are we how are we thinking
about the the Transcendent and the
divine
we're planting that seed in you Stephen
what's the first step for me I can't
tell you that that would be me divining
you the uh robbing you of your Divine
Your Divine path you have to figure that
out for yourself
I'll re I'll keep my eyes open okay
in the meantime while your eyes are open
uh everybody's eyes should be directed
to the Diary of a CEO podcast and the
new book of the same name
um again you did really a wonderful job
with this book thank you um even if you
have no interest in business it's really
a primer for how to think about your own
life how to prioritize your time your
resources your attention and if nothing
else it allows you to see the world more
clearly in the way that some of your
favorite companies operate to manipulate
you hijack your attention and Garner
your business
is there anything else what is the main
idea you want people to take away you've
nailed this book you've nailed it I have
nothing more to add and thank you so
much for inviting me onto your platform
you're someone that I've watched for
many many years and there's so much
about you that I admire that I realize I
will never I will never get to and again
maybe this is the distinction between
aspiration and admiration or something
but there's so much about the way you
conduct yourself the way you hold
yourself your values and your integrity
that I think I'm I'm still a little bit
short on but I aspire to get there
and it's it's Indescribable I don't even
know how I pointed it but it's the way
in which you carry yourself and the
clarity and of your intentions and how I
experience that that I would love to
replicate someday I'll get closer to so
you're a big role model for me in that
regard and that's why spending time with
you recording but also when we went to
watch Manchester United lose uh in
London was really wonderful because
um vicariously it's I I it's contagious
I can
part of it is sort of impressed upon me
so I I thank you for that I thank you
for inviting me onto your show because
it is one of the Legendary Shows out
there and so it's an honor I really uh I
I appreciate that that that that means a
lot Steve and it really does um it
touches me that you would say that my my
kind of reflexive reaction to that is to
deflect and also make sure that you
understand that I'm just riddled with
Character defects so whatever I'm
emanating please understand that I'm uh
You Know My Own Worst Enemy most of the
time but
um that means a lot you know I've I've
been watching you for quite some time
um and how you show up in public life
and I think it's incredibly admirable
and and impactful the integrity and the
thoughtfulness that you put into
um what you're sharing why you're
sharing it and how you're sharing it
particularly in contrast to this sort of
Entrepreneurship CEO wealth porn of
social media of people getting out of
you know sports cars and walking onto
private jets Etc I mean that's what
we're attuned to and you're modeling
something very different and and the
fact that you have become this powerful
role model for an entire new generation
of entrepreneurs business people
um and just people who are of influence
in the world I think is
um
is is very meaningful and I wish there
were more people out there like you and
the fact that
when I came and did your show which I
enjoyed tremendously you then extended
an invitation for me and and my kid to
join you out of Manchester United game
and I got to spend a whole afternoon
with you was an incredibly kind
gesture that uh I will not forget I
really appreciate appreciate what you do
and and how you do it thank you Rich I
don't know what else to say thank you
yeah so everybody check out Diary of a
CEO podcast book at Stephen on social at
Stephen Bartlett on Instagram now Steve
we're on Instagram and then Stephen
Barlow on Twitter yeah yeah okay all
right reversed yeah either way he's easy
to find right
um and next time you come to La please
try to hang out a little bit I look
forward to it thank you so much it's an
honor yeah really peace